in the last episode we had a bloody
brutal fight against Ludwig and at the
start of that fight do you remember this
guy he was the blood corpse that came
towards us in the opening cutscene well
on my second fight with Ludwig on a new
character I discovered that it's
possible for this guy to survive the
fight he didn't get hit once as Ludwig
stamped all over the place of course all
of my attempts just think about how
unlikely that is he's probably laughing
here like what the [ __ ] how did I
survive that on my other characters this
guy is dead even during the fights with
Ludwig that are still ongoing so I guess
you get one chance to save his life and
while I'm busy discovering all these
pointless things you guys are finding
some really cool stuff commenter AK
naught 92 in the last video found
something particularly awesome if you
talk to Ludwig's head after the boss
fight while wearing the garb of the
healing church then he says this tell me
good hunter of the church have you seen
the light on my church hunters the
Honorable Spartans
I hope they would be good that is a
relief to know I did not suffer such
denigration from nothing thank you
now I may sleep in peace even in this
darkest of night I see no I guess I
didn't have the heart to tell him that
his church hunters are now blood raving
lunatics I'll be checking out what
happens if you say no here though it
should make for some pretty sad stuff
for prepare to cry right telling him
that his life's work was for nothing
but it turns out there is one blade of
the healing church still alive and human
in the nightmare but always round on to
the church because shackle only hear the
true blades of the church he's reciting
some chant that the healing church
hunters must have learned to keep
themselves sane while hunting beasts the
repetition would have helped with
anyone's sanity and he's not the only
one who does this the next two
characters we meet in fact have their
own little chance going on that's very
odd the toll of the Bell
liar such pettiness will be your undoing
the Beast you see will not be found here
go back to your hunt and if you have the
chance put this behind you
we're going to be hearing that bell
before too long and it turns out it's
not a sound you want to hear at the end
of the hallway we find the fist of
gratia which belongs to this hulking
brute of a woman who didn't have the
dexterity to wield firearms and up ahead
we run into someone very familiar this
is almost certainly vicar Amelia right
it's the same chant we hear before her
boss fight the voice is the same and
it's her white garb
I'll be at less raggedy since this is
based in the past I think we know that
blood-crazed hunters ended up in the
nightmare so she must have ended up here
when we put her to rest in the waking
world you have to kill Amelia in the
waking world before you can even access
the DLC after all as the eye pendant we
found in the last video states this is
the Cathedral of the healing church that
contains their private research Hall the
church and the choir have long
experimented on patients in order to
gain insight and potentially ascend to
the status of great ones that much at
least is clear from the law we've
learned so far and this research Hall
can
we tell us a bit more about
anyone seeing my eyes drop the new photo
is this Eileen listen to the way she
says poodle poodle sounds like when she
says winter hunter the accent is the
same for sure and maybe the voice as
well but beyond that I guess we need a
bit more proof anyway the gameplay in
this area is interesting for me it was
the closest this series has come to
having a stealth based level I don't
know if everyone else experienced this
but I did because all throughout the
level you find these blue elixirs which
is a medicine that was used by the high
ministers of the healing church to numb
the brains of those they experimented on
and they're certainly appropriate here
in this research Hall teeming with
patients with enlarged heads our
character retains consciousness when
they drink this through sheer force of
will and we make use of the secondary
effect of the medicine which is to go
semi stealth and I couldn't always be
bothered killing every one of the
patients so often I would use this blue
elixir to scout out the level and I had
some pretty cool moments with it look at
this guy run past the souls games are
rare examples of games that actually
reward you for being observant some
bookcases for example have pressure
plates in front of them which when
pressed trigger the bookcases to attack
you that's the sentence I never thought
I'd say also take for example this huge
winding stairway some platforms you'll
notice are inaccessible which hints that
this staircase will rotate later on and
that you'll be rewarded for coming back
and exploring again I just really like
stuff that rewards the observant player
and being observant really does reward
you because the item you need here is
the lock shield a shield with such low
requirements the
pretty much any build can be able to use
it it protects you against non physical
damage and it's gonna be really useful
in the next boss fight they've also done
a really good job I think of not just
introducing new enemies but variations
on the same enemy I can't say the same
for games like destiny that charge you
$70 for an expansion with the same
enemies and the enemies just have a
different skin no in this game this tons
of new enemies and a lot of those
enemies like the enlarged head patients
they all have vastly different move sets
meaning you're always guessing moving on
a little bit the main law question for
this area is what was the church hoping
to achieve with these patients so let's
listen to some dialogue is that you
Thank You Maria know you're someone else
please could you do something for me
I need brain fluid murky mushy and brain
fluid you find this brain fluid on fully
developed heads the ones that talk about
the sounds that they're hearing lady
Maria bomba Robin well I grew up and
becoming there I would say you ready
Maria lady Maria say something anything
have you heard how curiously the siege
ends like a storm but like the rain only
gentle like dripping water it bellows
from diamond
me here comes up through my enzyme but
generally hype little droplets
the brain fluid reads extracted from a
patient whose head expanded until that
was all that they were these heads and
the patients that have them they're the
kind of insight experiments that you
would expect from the church clearly the
things they're saying have some
significance they're all related to
water they're not just the ramblings of
insane people the importance of large
bodies of water is actually referenced
in a lot of runes the lake runes for
example say that they serve as a bulwark
guarding sleep and an augur of the
eldritch truth they say that the
transcription of the great ones in human
voices
ripples like a watery reflection they
say that we must overcome the hindrances
of water and seek what is ours and in
the next video we'll learn a bit more
about what this means but just know for
now that these beings clearly have more
insight even though it's really specific
they're these enlarged heads that hear
the water and so will we
so one patient that hasn't completely
turned into a large head talks about
being a failure as if she's let down the
lady Maria who all the patients clearly
see as some caring motherly figure one
character in particular talks the most
she's called Saint Adeline and we help
her take three helpings of brain fluid
and then
I see a shape my guide I see your voice
clearly as it bends and bleeds my own
revelation just for me thank you for
everything
really I used to be nothing she's so
proud that she became something like she
finally had this purpose she gives you
the milkweed rune if you complete her
quest which turns us into this thing and
she also gives us the balcony key which
leads to the area that used to hold the
celestial emissaries in the waking world
it's more proof that these patients were
trying to be turned into kin or these
celestial emissaries the milkweed rune
reads a translation of the inhumane
sticky whispers that reveal the nature
of a celestial attendant sounds a lot
like a celestial emissary speaking of
failures this next boss the living
failures to me these things and by
extension the other creatures in the
research hall they all seem to be
attempts at creating Celestials in some
form and maybe even celestial emissaries
beings that can talk or communicate with
the great ones perhaps there are a lot
of similarities especially in regards to
where you fight them it's an interesting
boss every time you take one out another
one spawns and there's always going to
be four of them attacking you from all
sides they're incredibly slow but when
you deplete their huge health pool they
get bolder and more aggressive and more
frantic at around 50% health they start
casting meteor storms together which is
best defended against using that lock
shield that we picked up earlier as it
defends against arcane projectiles if
you're well positioned you can even get
a backstab off while
they cast the meteor shower which I
highly recommend because it's a way to
get in that much needed damage after
succeeding we talked to the wandering
hunter we're going to call him Simon for
reasons I'll explain later
oh hello not a pretty sight is it the
true face of the blood worshiping Beast
purging healing church but that's not
all you seek the secrets held by the
nightmare do not then here's what you
must do
climb the astral Clocktower and killed
Maria she hides the real secret
a corpse should be left well alone
oh I know very well how the secrets
beckons so sweetly only an honest death
will kill you now
read you from your wild curiosity lady
Maria so far all we know is that she's
the caretaker of the patients in the
clinic and that she hides the true
seeker
I am confident in saying that this was
my favorite fight in blood-borne so far
I love Hunter boss fights in this game
because they put you on what seems like
even footing with an opponent and it
allows you to make good use of the
health regain mechanic unlike most
beasts enemies that just flatten you in
one or two hits I hate that I love when
it's a fight way you can regain your
health you can probably parry her but I
wasn't gonna find out
I feel like spamming parry is a really
shitty way to do this fight I wanted to
dash around and use my reflexes and my
blades of mercy and I just wanted to get
through all of her phases that way and
as we're discovering every boss in the
old hunters has phases Maria is no
different she has three every time I
fought her I fought one stage further I
did this because her phases are actually
pretty well designed it's not like
fighting Ludwig where you find a
completely different version of him at
50% of his health no Maria trains you in
her attacks every phase simply upgrades
the attacks that she's already been
using meaning that earlier phases train
you for future phases and they reward
you for learning such a good fight and
I'll tell you now Maria is going to make
a fantastic prepare to cry story there
is so much interesting stuff to talk
about but we'll have to do it another
time
and let's talk a little bit about it so
as her set says she's an apprentice to
Germann someone who looked
to him though he had an affection for
her that she didn't seem to sense since
gurmann modeled the hunters dream it's
clear that the doll is actually modeled
after Maria this caretaker who shares
most of her physical attributes Maria is
a caretaker of the patients and the doll
is a caretaker of us there's a lot of
similarities there not just appearance
however Germann certainly seems
displeased with the doll in the dream
and for a man who is supposedly created
the doll out of love for another woman
he never interacts with her perhaps it's
because the doll has a completely
different personality maybe it's because
she's far less headstrong and way more
subservient he couldn't replicate who
Maria was in the dream but yeah lots to
talk about I'll see you guys in the next
one thank you for watching and it's time
to get into some secrets